das neue ziel im kampf gegen das virus
die 35 ist das neue 50 dass diese
incidents rasch erreicht wird hoffen
nicht nur geschäftsleute grenzkontrollen
gegen die korona mutation in deutschland
will die einreise aus tirol und
tschechien so weit wie möglich
einschränken
ihn hatte niemand auf der rechnung im
super-g gewinnt romed baumann
sensationell wm silber für deutschland
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
petra gerster dazu später mehr im sport
mit norbert lehmann der sagt gerne einen
guten abend auch von mir und darf man
hier herzlich willkommen die ko-runde
aus bund und ländern hat getagt und
dargelegt wie es weitergeht mit den
regeln die derzeit unser leben bestimmen
im bundestag verteidigt die kanzlerin
heute die entscheidung den shutdown
fortzusetzen
den abgeordneten bleibt nur kritik an
den beschlüssen
doch bevor wir zur eigentlichen
parlamentsdebatte kommen hier noch mal
die neue faktenlage kurz zusammengefasst
von anselm stern
und wieder wird verlängert bis
mindestens zum siebten märz gelten alle
maßnahmen grundsätzlich weiter
beschließen bund und länder beim
streitthema schule gibt es keine
einheitliche strategie jedes bundesland
kann selbst entscheiden wann und wie mit
welchen hygiene konzepten etwa schulen
und kitas wieder mehr geöffnet werden
eine sonderregelung gibt es für die
friseure
sie dürfen bereits ab dem ersten märz
auf machen mehr lockerungen etwa
einzelhandel oder museen öffnen das soll
jetzt erst ab einer sieben tage
incidence von weniger als 35
neuinfektionen möglich sein
bislang war da immer die 50 beide zahlen
stehen als marken im
infektionsschutzgesetz aus sorge vor den
mutationen sei nun der niedrige wert
gewählt worden heißt es aus dem
kanzleramt
im bundestag musste sich die kanzlerin
viel kritik an der verlängerung des
shutdowns anhören
vermisst wird vor allem ein
verbindlicher zeitplan wann es wieder
zurückgeht zum normalen leben und unter
welchen bedingungen die opposition
spricht von enttäuschten hoffnungen
britta spiekermann
angela merkel im bundestag die
beschlüsse gestern regierungserklärung
heute die kanzlerin verteidigte ihren
kurs verlängerung des schattens mein
ziel ist dass wir eben die neue welle
die kommen könnte wenn das neue virus
oberhand gewinnt dass wir der keinen
raum geben und nicht wieder einen
solchen exponentiellen anstieg von
zahlen haben die bund länder beschlüsse
es gibt viel kritik die opposition sieht
sich ausgeschlossen von
entscheidungsprozessen auf die
zuschauerrolle reduziert das müsse sich
ändern
dann müssen wir es tun von hier aus in
diesem parlament beschließen im
bundesrat beschließen dann haben wir
eine transparente eindeutige gemeinsame
haltung mehr parlament weniger bund
länder entscheidungen fordert auch die
linkspartei und beklagt vor allem dass
impft debakel sie haben auch heute
wieder 0 selbst kritik geäußert aber
vergleichsweise viel selbstgefälligkeit
auch eine bundeskanzlerin steht ein
gewisses maß ein mindestmaß an
selbstkritik gut zu gesicht
schleppende wirtschaftshilfen noch so
ein kritikpunkt vor allem der fdp und
der grünen es sei nur ein hin- und
herschieben zwischen finanz- und
wirtschaftsminister zudem es gebe wir
keine perspektive für einzelhandel und
gastronomie hoffnungen sind enttäuscht
worden wenn viele menschen haben sich
mehr erwartet als einen frischen
haarschnitt meinte er in anspielung
darauf dass nur friseur ab dem ersten
märz aufmachen dürfen ansonsten strenge
kriterien veröff nungen 35er incident
statt 50 die afg zieht die korona
politik grundsätzlich in zweifel
die collage in ihrer methode von
einsperren und dicht machen wachsen ins
unermessliche
die spd springt der kanzlerin bei die
afg habe corona verharmlost sie haben
dazu beigetragen dass manche gefahren
verkannt worden
sie haben sich schuldig gemacht nach
langer debatte der kernvorwurf der
opposition merkel und die länder machten
corona politik im alleingang die
kanzlerin versichert wir handeln
rechtmäßig und jetzt der blick auf die
aktuellen corona zahlen sie sinken
weiter
das robert koch institut registrierte
10.000 237 neue infektionen innerhalb
eines tages das sind fast 4000 weniger
als vergangenen donnerstag 666 weitere
menschen sind an oder mit dem virus
gestorben die bundesweite 7 tages
incident sank auf 64 den grenzwert von
35 und weniger erreichen 55 landkreise
hier graue markiert nachdem corona
beschlüssen ist die enttäuschung in der
wirtschaft groß mehrere verbände
kritisieren dass die politik keine
öffnungs perspektive gegeben habe der
handelsverband spricht von wortbruch
viele geschäftsleute stünden am rande
des ruins nur die friseure dürften sich
freuen sie können bald wieder öffnen
volker dutschek vorübergehend
geschlossen die lichter in diesem
friseursalon sind vor acht wochen
ausgegangen bei magdalena preis im
westfälischen ibbenbüren stellt jetzt
aber wieder das telefon ununterbrochen
am ersten märz soll es losgehen
ich kann ihnen um 19 uhr 30
die friseurmeisterin musste in den
letzten wochen ohne die versprochenen
zuschüsse über die runden kommen
die überbrückungshilfen 3 die für uns
friseure da sein sollten sind nicht da
das kurzarbeitergeld ist auch schleppen
die müssen halt die mitarbeiter
vorfinanzieren und es ist schon
beträchtlich für einen friseursalon die
zuschüsse fließen nicht oder nutzen
viele einzelhändler fühlen sich im stich
gelassen wir befürchten eine dramatische
situation in den innenstädten für viele
textile modehändler kann das aus
bedeuten das sind wahrscheinlich weit
mehr als 50.000 unternehmen die jetzt
aufgeben müssen eigentliches thilo
ziegler konzertveranstalter er hat
umgesattelt und betreibt seit heute ein
privates coroner testzentrum im saarland
wie aus der branche konzerte und
musikfestivals sind jetzt seit einem
jahr im block dauern und wir hatten auch
keine lust mehr am seitenrand zu stehen
und uns das anzuschauen und wir glauben
dass man das spiel testen vielleicht
auch wieder einen schritt schneller ins
soziale leben zurück kommt die
einheitsfront bröckelt niedersachsen
wird bereits ab samstag blumenläden und
gartencenter öffnen
andere länder wollen nachziehen es wird
ein vorsichtiger start in das neue
schule halbjahr die meisten bundesländer
planen ab dem 22
februar zum präsenzunterricht
zurückzukehren zunächst nur für
grundschüler und nur schrittweise
wie das allerdings konkret funktionieren
soll ist vielen schulen unklar
petra otto den stundenplan den würde sie
gerne planen für montag nach den
faschingsferien wenn es hier wieder
losgeht aber wie bisher nichts konkretes
aus dem ministerium wechsel unterricht
ja was heißt das genau
mir fehlt an konkreten vorgaben welche
klassenstufen darf ich kombinieren darf
ich überhaupt kombinieren oder es immer
nur eine klasse im wechsel betrieb da
was darf ich überhaupt unterrichten
es gab eine zeit in der singen absolut
verboten war ist das wieder so
oder kann ich auch anders planen fest
steht in den klassenzimmern darf nur die
halbe besetzung platz nehmen weniger
schüler brauchen aber
der lehrkräfte die sie nicht hat und der
präsenzunterricht ist ja nicht das
einzige
wir müssen ja auch die verschuldung
stemmen und auch die notbetreuung also
drei verschiedene säulen dreibeine
nebeneinander und meinen kolleginnen
sind zum teil wirklich am limit immerhin
gerade eingetroffen gute masken
bisher mussten grundschullehrkräfte gar
keine tragenden baden württemberg jetzt
machen die virus mutanten zunehmend
sorge
die kultusministerin alarmiert was ganz
wichtig ist ist die weiterentwicklung
der test strategie damit wir infizierte
von nicht infizierten trennen können und
deshalb ist es was wo erzieherinnen
erzieher und lehrkräfte jetzt dann
beginnen wenn wir wieder öffnen
zweimal die woche sich kostenlos schnell
testen lassen können
sie hofft dass sie morgen mehr weiß denn
sie muss den eltern und kolleginnen doch
noch vor den ferien sagen wie es danach
weitergeht
die größte sorge ist er derzeit dass
sich ansteckende virus mutationen in
deutschland ausbreiten
deshalb hat die bundesregierung ab
sonntag neue einreisebeschränkungen für
österreich und tschechien beschlossen
das bedeutet auch wieder strenge
kontrollen an den grenzen zu beiden
nachbarländern in tirol aber auch in
einigen grenznahen gebieten tschechiens
sind die virus mutation aus südafrika
und großbritannien auf dem vormarsch da
fragen wir dazu theo koll theo
eigentlich wollte man nach den
erfahrungen im letzten frühjahr doch in
der eu keine grenzen mehr schließen
aber jetzt geht es jetzt auch in diese
richtung warum naja weil unter anderem
das nachbarland tschechien aktuell
besonders stark von der krise betroffen
ist wenn man es auf deutsche
bevölkerungsstärke umrechnet dann hätte
das land heute über 70.000
neuinfektionen gehabt und offensichtlich
ist der anteil der ansteckenden mutanten
dabei besonders gut in der folge sind
die angrenzenden bundesländer sachsen
und bayern dann besonders betroffen weil
positiv getesteten pendlern aus
tschechien soll der anteil der mutierten
variante bereits 40 bis 70 prozent
betragen die genauen ausnahmen von der
einreisebeschränkungen werden im moment
noch in der bundesregierung abgestimmt
denn
beispielsweise die deutsche
autoindustrie ist natürlich massiv von
zulieferungen auch aus tschechien
abhängig ministerpräsident kretschmann
hat heute sogar im extremfall
grenzschließungen nicht mehr
ausgeschlossen je nachdem wie stark sich
die virusvarianten ausbreiten vielen
dank theo in die usa zum im pitch bend
verfahren gegen donald trump und da
führten die ankläger gestern vor augen
wie dramatisch und gefährlicher sturm
von trump anhängern aufs capitol am
sechsten januar war auf bislang
unveröffentlichten video ist zu sehen
wie abgeordnete und senatoren
aber auch der damalige vizepräsident
pence teilweise in letzter sekunde in
sicherheit gebracht wurden
britta jäger hängt mike pence schreit
die meute draußen und dringt ins capitol
ein überwachungskameras zeigen wie der
damalige vizepräsident in sicherheit
gebracht wird der mob sucht auch nach
der demokratin nancy pelosi
[Musik]
ein polizist ruft verzweifelt nach
verstärkung
es sind auch bislang unveröffentlichte
bild und tonaufnahmen die demokraten als
beweise im prozess vorliegen und in
zeitlichen zusammenhang setzen zu
aussagen trumps um zu zeigen wie der
nicht aufhörte die männer anzustacheln
dollar john twittert gerade das bike
pants uns im stich gelassen hat seine
falschen behauptungen über wahlbetrug
hat er wie einen trommelschlag
eingesetzt um sie zu inspirieren und sie
anzuheizen damit sie wütend werden
trump sei der choreograf der capitol
erstürmung gewesen
der präsident hat uns dazu eingeladen
für die demokraten sind die beweise
erdrückend
und doch will die mehrheit der
republikaner nach wie vor keinen
schuldspruch tram nicht verbieten jemals
wieder ein politisches amt zu übernehmen
die stimmen für nicht schuldig dürften
heute mehr geworden sein ich denke die
meisten republikaner fanden die
präsentation der anklage absurd ab
morgen sind rams verteidiger am zug
dessen verurteilung weiter so gut wie
ausgeschlossen ist die benötigte
zwei-drittel-mehrheit werden die
demokraten wohl nicht erreichen
trotz ihrer emotionalen präsentation
nach dem tödlichen messerangriff in
dresden anfang oktober hat die
bundesanwaltschaft laut zdf
informationen anklage erhoben der
mutmaßliche attentäter soll aus
islamistischen und
homosexuellenfeindliche motiven zwei
touristen niedergestochen haben
ein mann starb das andere opfer
überlebte schwer verletzt
ob und wann es zum prozess kommt
entscheidet das oberlandesgericht
dresden zum winterwetter und seinen
folgen deutschland friert weiter
arktische polarluft hält alles im griff
heute war es so fast überall sonnig aber
zugleich fast überall unter null grad
die klirrende kälte ist ein echtes
problem immer noch auch im bahnverkehr
und zugefrorene wasserstraßen
an den binnenschiffern zu schaffen
wilhelm tacke eisbrecher flügen durch
zugefrorene wasserstraßen auf den neben
kanälen der weser brechen wie immer
wieder die eisdecke auf damit die
frachtschiffe fahren können
und sie sorgen dafür dass sich vor den
wären keine eisschollen auftürmen weil
dafür alle eisbrecher auch vom
mittellandkanal abgezogen wurden kommen
die binnenschiffer hier nicht mehr durch
der kanal zugefroren zwangspause im
braunschweiger hafen auch hier wenn es
noch eine woche und gehalt nichts machen
das haben sie auch ein bisschen schade
für den betrieb für die firma da komme
ich auch kein geld rein leere regale auf
wangerooge frische lebensmittel sind
knapp weil der fährverkehr zur
ostfriesischen insel wegen eisgang in
der fahrrinne eingestellt wurde
gemüse und obst müssen mit dem flugzeug
eingeflogen werden
in der luft unterwegs ist auch die
deutsche bahn um zu sehen was da unten
los ist auf der ic strecke zwischen
berlin und münchen sieht nicht gut aus
bei erfurt muss noch viel schnee geräumt
werden
dafür setzt die bahn schneefräsen 1
damit die züge wieder fahren können
corona macht alles anders auch für
kinofans zur stunde wäre es losgegangen
für die berlinale
stattdessen wird das weltgrößte
publikums filmfest verschoben vorhang
auf für premieren galas und glamour
heißt es erst im sommer hier bilder aus
den vorjahren
trotzdem dreht sich schon heute alles um
den goldenen bären
denn es wurde bekannt wer um die
auszeichnung wetteifert nadia nasser
verrät es uns schneewehen stadt star
rummel am potsdamer platz
auch die berlinale ein opfer der
pandemie heute abend würde es hier
eigentlich so aussehen wenn sie den
stattgefunden hätte die eröffnung der
filmfestspiele sonst anziehungspunkt für
weltstars wie
cate blanchett tilda swinton george
clooney oder die rolling stones anfang
märz gibt es jetzt ein reines online
festival im juni dann ein summer special
mit publikum heute verkündeten die
berlinale leiter die wettbewerbsfilme
und gleich vier von den 15 stammen aus
deutschland
die berlinale ist sehr wichtig für die
deutsche filmwelt und alle filmemacher
sind bei uns im wettbewerb geblieben
auch als wir unser konzept leider in den
osten mit im rennen die erste
regiearbeit von schauspieler daniel
brühl nebenan und die zdf-koproduktion
fabian ein film von dominik graf nach
dem roman von erich kästner
ein bewegender blick auf die letzten
jahre der weimarer republik
der moment der welt premiere ist
eigentlich immer ein wahnsinnig
wichtiger und auch emotionaler moment wo
die arbeit das licht der welt erblickt
das findet nun mehr oder weniger hinter
verschlossenen türen statt gleichzeitig
ist es gut dass dieses festival sich
dazu entschieden hat trotzdem stadt zu
finden filmfans müssen jetzt auf den
juni hoffen
eingeladen zum publikums event sind
stars wie michelle pfeiffer jodie foster
benedict cumberbatch oder michael caine
wenn es die pandemie erlaubt na
hoffentlich und nun zur alpinen ski wm
in cortina d'ampezzo mitarbeiter und die
ist heute wetterbedingt mit drei tagen
verspätung endlich gestartet
und mit einem paukenschlag für das
deutsche team romed baumann holt im
super-g überraschend die silbermedaille
und ist nur sieben hundertstel langsamer
als der sieger aus österreich mit mut
zum risiko und einer nervenstarken
vaters der gebürtige tiroler romed
baumann über die wm fristet für
österreich bei der 35 jährige vor zwei
jahren nicht mehr gut genug nach dem
wechsel zum deutschen skiverband gelingt
denn jetzt sein größter erfolg silber um
sieben hundertstel hinter seinem
früheren landsmann vincent kriechmayr
und vor dem franzosen alexis pinturault
den weg gelegt hat bestritten hat nur
funktioniert weil immer neues umfeld ob
der mich unterstützt haben dies möglich
gemacht habe und riesengroßes dankeschön
es ist das beste wm ergebnis eines
deutschen ski fahrers im super-g und
beim super g der frauen wurde kira
weiter aus als beste deutsche
neunzehnter erfolgreich heute die
deutschen skeletonis bei der wm in
altenberg die männer nach zwei von vier
läufen auf den plätzen zwei und drei bei
den frauen jacqueline jörling sogar in
führung
jacqueline sich voller zuversicht sagte
am ersten tag gerade hat sich die 26
jährige an der nach dem ersten lauf noch
führenden russen nikita vorbei auf rang
eins geschoben
trotz ihres schon legendär schwachen
starts gelang der weltmeisterin von 2017
dies dank ihrer fabelhaften fahrerischen
klasse
so geht die 26-jährige mit dem skeleton
hauch von elf hundertstel sekunden
vorsprung auf tina und 24 hundertstel
auf teamgefährtin und titelverteidigerin
tina herrmann in die entscheidenden
beiden läufe von altenberg zum tennis
mona barthel ist bei den australian open
in der zweiten runde gescheitert
die 30-jährige verlor mit 4 6 und 1 6
gegen die tschechin karolina war
damit ist auch die letzte deutsche
spielerin in melbourne ausgeschieden das
schlechteste abschneiden der frauen bei
einem grand-slam-turnier seit über zehn
jahren und bei den männern ist ja noch
alexander zverev dabei als letzter
deutscher im einzel der spielt heute
nacht gegen den franzosen adrian
mannarino danken aber bitteschön auch
für närrinnen und die jecken war es kein
guter tag denn eigentlich fällt weiter
fasst nach der krone bedingt aus und
doch war die eine oder andere bunte
figur zu sehen in den
karnevalshochburgen ein paar jecken mit
guter laune trotz alkohol und feiern
und auch einen traditionellen weiber
überfall auf ein stadt oder gab es der
schlips ist ab die masten bleiben dran
die kälte krallt sich weiter in
deutschland fest die details zum bitte
gleich von katja huhn ist das was von
uns schön dass sie dabei waren
marietta slomka erwartet sie um viertel
vor zehn zum heute journal
und wir sind morgen wieder da wenn sie
mögen bis dahin einen entspannten abend